Nói 2 mệt tâm tâm sống ngoại trường Iran Abbas Arachitin bố Iran sẵn sản nối lại đàn phản thuy Mỹ
lên quan tây truy trình ham nhăn nhưng nhảm mạnh lối thoại chữ thế giễn sản trên những tăng tôn trọc
và công hiện類 đủ phẩm giá khu dạy Iran. Ông Arachit khẩn định tổng thông thông vi đường trăm cần thay đổi giống điều
nếu muốn đảnh đủ thật thòn. Cho rằng tiền chi sẽ giận tử thiện chi, tôn trọng sẽ giận tử tôn trọng
dời phần tích nhận định phân muôn này là lời nhắn sống sản từ tây Iran sẵn
có cuộc tương lượng Trung tương lai phải công nhận vị thế giễn chỉ và phân quả của Iran.
Chúc vì đó, phía Mỹ hiện chưa đưa ra phản hồi chính thức về tuyên muôn này
về phần mình yên xerain vẫn tổng só quan điểm, phần đối bất kỳ sĩnh nhận bộ nào Mỹ
Iran chưa rằng tây Iran tí tục theo đổi các thàn phọng về hàng nhăn. Chúc vì đó, ông
màn nước chung săm tiếp tục thuộc đẩy nối lại đối thoại giữa hai bên, sau năm phòng đàn phản giản
tí tên giản giản giản giản tự thần tư, tính chiến lối lại đàn phản sẽ còn phụ thuộc
và mức lộ linh qua từ cả hai phía, đã biết là chung mối khảnh khu vực con nhiều bất đồn.